Good morning to all of you.
It is for me 1 pleasure and 1 honor
today to announce the agreement between Podemos and Alianza Verde
to compete jointly
1 time more to the next elections
European elections on June 9.
We think
01 of the most important things we have
in politics is precisely loyalty,
working together,
the ability to understand each other
with those who are not exactly
the same as us
but they work for the same
objectives that we pursue.
And from our point of view,
from the point of view of we can,
we believe that Green Alliance,
and particularly
Juancho López de uralde,
its leader,
is 1 of the persons and 1 of the organizations
that has contributed the most
to progress in combating the emergency
climate in our country.
Without Juancho
some of the most important advances would be understood,
such as the prohibition of fracking or as
all the ambition we could
incorporate him to this anti-change law
climatic.
Hey,
it's a lot of years of struggle,
from social a to political a
and well,
to be able to tell
with Alianza
Green on this one in this upcoming election
is very important to us
because we know very well to what extent
the fight against the climate emergency
has to be 1 of the political axes
of our space,
because our lives are really VA in it.
So well,
we come to reinforce 1 candidacy
already very powerful.
"I want to thank Irene Montero once again,
to lead this proposal.
We have 1 task ahead of us,
immense,
but I think it is tucked in by the best equipment,
from Isabel Serra to Pablo,
but also serín,
in Valle,
Marcan Broye or Diego Cañamero himself.
So a lot of strength
go ahead and I am convinced that together
we will be able to put back
standing to the transforming left in Spain.
Thank you very much!